[Music]
when the
universe,
the Cuban national health system is
destroyed, the consultants are in very
poor condition, the hospitals are
overcrowded, the people dying in the
corridors, the patients without oxygen,
hospitals without electricity,
that is
how people upload social networks,
those  pure reality
since the communist revolution of 1959
hundreds of newspaper articles,
reports and documentaries have celebrated
the supposed marvel of the
Cuban health system
tex
Universo
[Música]
detective el optician de health system
everything is part of an elaborate
propaganda campaign that distorts the
reality of the  Cuban medical care in
reality the clinics lack
routine supplies including
antibiotics bandages syringes
oxygen and in some cases
running water patients occupy the
corridors because there are not enough
doctors to treat their most
basic needs and their hospitals are unsanitary
and say  Repeatedly for decades
, Cuban medical care has been that of a country
impoverished by communism. The only thing
that is new is that due to social networks
and the pandemic, the façade of the regime has
finally crumbled.
The propaganda attack of
the Cuban regime has been so successful that
at the beginning  In 2021, some reporters
claimed that Cuba's response
to the pandemic had been exemplary
in the world. Three months after that
broadcast, Cubans protested
against the regime in the streets and on
social networks such as Twitter and Facebook.
In part, their outrage arose as a result
of the  precarious state of the cuban health system
during the pandemic
[Music]
and they left me
since 2007 when filmmaker michael
moore lied to the public in his
documentary 5 which celebrates the
cuban medical system
ordinary citizens have been equipped
with mobile phones twitter  instagram
and facebook which allows them to publish
the truth about their real experience
in the  cuban hospitals schewinsteiger
the youtube hub violas de pauta active
in javier sesma sachs grape liquor today they
inhabit legal pulse well michael
woman
victim poetic which today is presented
here van acker security systems son
jhon jaime join one of the state
time in tweet marie  auel la ues author
analyst and founder of tu barca and a
research center that promotes
human rights
in
dismantling
and not believing weinstein federico city
so many various paths of implants or
origin
extinct cuba media partner in total songs
on youtube they admire facebook a  tale again
my people were post english how the
cuban propaganda machine managed to deceive
so many people for so long
mainly through the myth of the
so-called medical missions abroad
since the 1960s cuba sends
teams of health professionals to
different countries  to provide
medical care your doctor has been educated in the
idea of saving life castr
env  The first Algerian medical mission was
launched in 1963 after the fall of the
Soviet Union when the regime lost
its main source of subsidies Cuba
intensified the program to fill
its very small coffers with money The
Cuban regime assures that its
medical missions are a humanitarian feat that
demonstrates  the altruistic spirit of
communism and its political project in 1960
ernesto alias che guevara proclaimed the
south the revolutionary doctor and announced
that individualism had to disappear
in cuba' told the story of a group of
doctors in havana who demanded certain
financial compensation to go  to the
rural areas of the country to attend to the
sick he dreamed of replacing them with
a new class of doctors drawn from the
peasantry those peasants he said
would have run immediately and with
all enthusiasm to help their
brothers our country will be able to
send doctors who are most needed
dark corners of the world
this will be a battle of solidarity  d
against selfishness such is the quote by
fidel castro that is inscribed on the
wall of the medical school of the
university of havana next to it there is
a map that shows all the places in
the world where the cuban medical missions have been
and
their  payroll because when you give an
award to a brigade none of the
people who participated in different
things are going to receive that award
there they are going to give them a diploma and applause they are
going to continue working new more ipad and
the world is going to continue thinking that  what they
are doing is right it is not right
that they use people for the
benefit of a government in 2013
doctor rod se ríos molina participated in
the cuban medical mission in sierra leone
where doctors from numerous countries
helped contain the lula
el epidemic  The Cuban regime promised the
members of the mission that when they returned to
the island they would be received as heroes and
that the state would give each of them a new car,
how much did you receive?
erra leon well in sierra leone we don't
receive a salary at all no the problem
was that cuba said he told us
that we were volunteers
volunteers i looked up what an epidemic was like that was
so deadly so deadly and even that it was
thought that a large number
of people could die  attended
that mission
they told us that we were
volunteering for solidarity rivers says
he received a per bien to cover his living
expenses meanwhile the
doctors from other countries were
generously paid and it turns out
that all the people who were there
from other entities for example  the
world health organization doctors from
spain from canada doctors and even here the
usa from doctors without borders who
were working there were
also volunteers for the shutdown which
was the difference however the
doctors from other countries who worked
with me and who we had the opportunity to
compensate
earned  seven thousand dollars a month
means that it is e  they were playing
life but they were receiving
monetary compensation for what they
were
doing doctor josé Ángel sánchez was part
of a medical mission in venezuela until
he escaped in 2015 he points out that the
host countries pay for these
services and that the money goes
directly  to the coffers of the
Cuban regime but not to the doctors who do their
work in the field and a payment
of around seven
thousand dollars for doctors to the
Cuban government at that time and the Cuban government in turn
paid each doctor 0  0.03 percent
that would come one hundred and 56 dollars a month
no more than that the myth of
altruistic and disinterested Cuban doctors
began to crack in 2000
when two doctors from the mission in
Zimbabwe managed to desert at the
johannesburg airport where they
denounced that they were  kidnapped the
doctors had denounced the
castro regime and take them back to cuba
against their will possibly to
go to jail  cel, however, managed
to reach the United States where they received political asylum.
In a 2020 human
rightswatch report, it concluded that
Cuban medical missions violate the
fundamental rights of doctors, including
the right to privacy as well
as freedom of expression, association and
movement, among others.  They pointed out that
many doctors feel pressured
to participate in the missions and fear
reprisals if they do not do so.
Governments that accept Cuban assistance
despite their abusive conditions
run the risk of becoming
accomplices in human rights
violations.
record plant angelides
so traditional green original trent
expect natural interest from doctors eu
conditions of 26 sell when I say
snacks that fear people hold on
senator they withheld the dividend the
implement is the travel pretend
forster and perfect incentive that they do not
toast with them in the  divan where
mentioned in the headquarters of g  continuous
or dead good dimension of
investment gloves tends to highlight water wherever
leave compton pre-sale is active due to
list of specific
defects of the united states in 2006 the
george w bush administration created a
parole program for
cuban medical professionals this
granted them  permanent resident status for cuban health workers
deployed abroad
if they
managed to reach a us consulate
more than 7,000 medical workers
took advantage of the opportunity
president barack obama canceled this
project at the request of the government 4
because obviously it is a project that
removed or  doctor
Julio César Alfonso is the president of
the Solidarity Without Borders Foundation,
which helps Cuban doctors
who have managed to escape from the regime.
This program works perfectly. It
had some
irregularities during the years that it
worked, but it flowed quite well in
the  2014 the team and  newspaper of the new york
times' spoke out against the
existence of the program
US immigration policy argued it
should not exacerbate the brain drain of
a hostile nation that is, the rights
of doctors to decide where they
want to live and work should be
subordinated to what  it suits the
Cuban regime there is some possibility of
some way that it can be re-
established and even now
there has not been much progress in this regard
but we continue to push
through different contacts
everywhere to try to re-establish some
kind that benefits these professionals
escaping from this slavery but
so far there has not been much
success but the most positive thing is to try to
stop this from happening and that
is what the international community must work on
after his stay in sierra leone
doctor rios fascinated a new  mission
in mexico at the beginning he was in a
military base in the capital one day he and his
c  friends were able to go out to buy
phone cards in order to
communicate with their families he decided to
escape I fell behind in the
group when we were already on the street and
there was a metro station la hd as
if it were time counting down saturdays i
ran out
of lml  I begged the
officer who was there and the man, thank
God, put the card in and let me in.
Death
advanced
222 subway stops and came to the
surface again. I called some
patients, half of whom were doctors,
and it's more outside, I told him look at
this sale.  address reported doctor
rios was able to work in a pharmacy on
the outskirts of mexico city where he was
able to save enough money to
pay a coyote to take them
to the us border after entering
the country he was detained by immigration police he was
held captive for  42 days
is pretty bad you're detained in a
place like it's more for me I don't know I've
never had the opportunity to go
to a chamber  rcel and
nation will be today in 2018 a group of
Cuban doctors who had managed to
escape from command missions to
the Pan American Health Organization
which is part of the
World Health Organization said entity argues the
doctors supports drug trafficking  people
and profits from having obtained 75
million dollars for acting as an intermediary
between cuba and the host countries the
world health organization and the
pan-american health organization
are direct protagonists in this
illicit program of trafficking of those they
have a leading role  in this
situation because they are the ones who
directly manage the contracts with the
Cuban government of almost all the
countries where this type of
activity is carried out they are funds from the united nations they
are funds that the majority
come from the usa and if they go to
the coffers  of a regime is totally
totalitarian it is something really
incredible through the medical missions the
Cuban regime  Or does it sell its
health services abroad? In the meantime, how is
the health service working for
the island's inhabitants
because the rest don't?
the syringes that are sterilized during the day
to be able to inject a
patient the speculums that are the
instrument with which
vaginal exams are performed on pregnant women
or any woman
when they put on a documentary they put on a
better polyclinic they put on a better
hospital for example me before  to come
here I worked in a national clinic for
two years before coming to an
international clinic where the
rich value tourists who work at
the clinic go, they don't know if it was to say
that it is on the beach there, of course,
the care is better
there  there are all the medicines there are
all the diagnostic means to make
the patients the beds are different
of course  this is that is tourism see a
tourist and the first thing he thinks is that he is
going to leave you 20 dollars
because he is going to solve you with 20 dollars
you are going to have more than the salary you
have as a whole so that
patient you prioritize
it gives him  the best care because it is the
way to get ahead there are
two health systems in cuba one
for the common population and the other
for tourism and elite personnel
when the defenders of the
cuban health system admit that there are
deficiencies usually  They attribute them
to the US embargo, which has
been systematically maintained since 1962,
but the deplorable conditions in
Cuban hospitals are more due to the lack
of basic medical care supplies
that are readily available
in other countries, such as antibiotics and
steroids in Cuban hospitals.
there is also a shortage of beds and stretchers
and they were without water for periods
of six hours twice a day at the
worst time  of the pandemic, but how
does the embargo really impact
Cuban medical care? Technically, the
embargo has not applied to medical products
since 1992 when the US approved the
democracy law in Cuba. However, the
law stipulates that
US pharmaceutical companies require
a license to sell their products.  products
in which critics are correct in pointing out
that this bureaucratizes the process between
2003 and 2021 cuba only bought 1.4
million dollars a year of
US medical products while the
market could be one of 50 to 100
million dollars a year but that
minimum level of  sales is not due to
the licensing process u.s.
companies would be happy to get the
necessary permits to sell their
products to cuba if the
profits will be worth the effort but
cuba suffers from a severe shortage of
foreign exchange because it produces fewer goods and
services than the rest of the world  world wants to
buy and someone busy with the government
of all
those faults good because rum alcoholic
beverages are lacking
yes cigarettes are
not lacking either defenders of the
cuban health system usually refer to the
infant mortality rate as
supposed evidence of its success
[Music]
intel and united states how is it possible
that according to the statistics  officials an
American baby has a
probability of dying that exceeds that of
a Cuban baby by more than 50%
columnist nicholas kristof asked himself
in the new york times three years ago
christophe analyzed one of the most
repeated figures to support the supposed
exceptionality of the  cuban health system
christophe admitted that the figures
should be taken with a dose of
skepticism however he chose to
interpret them to support the
dominant narrative cuba has the
public health system that many americans dream of
for example the
figures published by the cuban regime about
her
a very low infant mortality rate
in cuba 12 manipulate
cuba usa  various strategies to
manipulate its infant mortality rate
for example it ensures that
fetuses least likely to survive
outside the womb never have a
chance to be born there is
significant evidence that Cuban doctors
force women to abort fetuses that
show abnormalities after ultrasound scans
routine I am going to
stop being targets in transit windows
targets of 6 x vincent that the bear is
an assistant professor of economics at
george mason university in 2018 he
co-authored an article that argues that
the low infant mortality rate in
cuba is the  result of a
misclassification using an
indicator known as
late fetal deaths time to return action january
the first hernandez davy
classified the ebers exam ashley filders ok
test paper defects
and we can't win walker 70 del
rey  show
live and general manager of ford
westerns with three spring
sexual
lab  oral curves of the wire redford channel
have different records in order the
study is represented these days have
been from the activation rates of the
weight market things hi stable
are country in crisis go to hardware of
sun times wise huelves despite the
reports that assured that  cuba had
a successful strategy against the
pandemic
united states and accounting
team ser bailan and suddenly there was an
outbreak that collapsed all services
in august 2021 the new york times
reported that the Cuban health system was
reeling as its
supplies of oxygen and  syringes
while the morgues and
crematoriums were overwhelmed
as expected the dictator miguel diaz
canel blamed the
united states trade embargo on the doctors uploading
videos for social of the chaos that there
were people saying no the
medicine
there are no doctors means that
is that it doesn't work right now the
island collapsed the health system collapsed
the  overcrowded hospitals people
dying in the corridors patients
without oxygen hospitals without electricity
do not have enough
strength or energy to treat
this is a case of this
magnitude Dr. Ríos has three children ages 7, 12
and 16 who still live in
Cuba He hopes to be able to bring them to
the United States soon,
because in Cuba, being a medical specialist
with so many years, it could not be, although it is only
right now I am working as
a carpentry assistant
and I have been a specialist for more than 8 years,
but I do not care because as a
carpentry assistant I can  support myself and I can
help support my mother, for example,
to support my children in Cuba
[Music]
I said I wanted to be a friend when I was 9 years old,
but until that happens I have to
do whatever I have to do
and you want them to want to be
The Cuban people are really going to wake up
the human product is going to rise up
stronger than ever the Cuban people
realized that there was no enemy
abroad nor a previous enemy the
enemy of the Cuban people
is the Cuban government
[Music]